so on friday you know what we did what
kalani and i
i go let's go to the set we're going to
go for your show
yeah do you have long day i did she met
jenna fisher
dan oliver hudson she met what's is the
guy's name oh um
oh my god why did i block all of a
sudden
portlandia portlandia fred armstrong
god yeah fred harmerson was there you
know what he said to me
what are you doing here you
i almost get so angry might be a bit
because it's fred armistice no no no no
no you know how i you know how i took it
wow i don't work a lot and
it's a shock you know who else did that
to me and it burned the
my bridges with them who years ago oh
man
years ago oh no i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] about this one
exclusive
years ago neil brennan comes up to me
and goes
hey you know seth right myers i go yeah
let's go to his birthday party it's up
the street right
so i go i think i can go he's like yeah
cause josh is there
i just talked to them you can come so i
went to the party
and then some guy walks up to me i'm
gonna say his name
and he looks at me not even joking when
he's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
here
that way immediately the bridge is
burned
forever this guy i've been talking [ __ ]
about this guy i can't anymore because
there's too much
there's a little bit of a sensitivity
because of this job that i have now
that's in that world so i can't see it
can you whisper it in my ear
no okay oh now i'm so like okay i'll you
want to play a trivia game
yeah okay can you get the guess who it
is yeah okay okay
it's somebody that i work with now on
the show that i have now
it was she worked with this guy on
another show
hold on hold on she worked with this guy
on another show i wouldn't know you'd
probably know better um
yeah god that that does not help
that help okay oh i know it is who is
that yes who is it
say it just say it no i won't say it
what yes
wow that was good because i'm gonna
and i it this could all be in my head
but i don't think it is
all in your head i'll tell you what i
tell you what's going on he loves it
i'll tell you why it's not in my head
why
because then a couple years after that i
was at m cafe
and i sat next i sat next right next to
him
right and he was sitting there talking
literally we were like side by side
and i kind of leaned to my left just so
he can see my face
and he kind of looked up at me and just
started it if he was gonna if he went
hey i'd be like what's up you know what
i mean but he just kind of looked up and
then went back into his meal and started
talking to him
he dissed me there so with what are you
doing here
to looking up at me at m cafe that
bridge is very [ __ ] on not a good
foundation
i have a question but here's my last
thing though is this yeah
but here's why this is why i'm mad
because when he first moved into town
you know who bonnie mcfarland is
rich vlas's wife yeah okay
years ago bonnie was at the comedy store
and had just moved into town or whatever
and bonnie goes
ye because back then i was sober but i
so i had all these connections to all
these
nightclubs that would go to nightclubs i
would go to like hollywood like scenes
imagine i know but back then i was like
i couldn't get laid you know i was newly
sober
i was on mad tv i was like i gotta get
this going you went robin
yeah i went club i did not know you were
a clubber i'm not a clubber but i went
clubbing
he's a clubber it turns out i want to
unpack this more what was yours
on monday night what did you wear to the
club oh i look good
i got a whole diesel because i have
there's some old diesel clothes